hello everyone welcome to today's live
broadcast combining practical training
with virtual training and continuous
development of lab animal vets I'm
Robert Castellanos of lab roots and i'll
be your moderator for today's event we
are delighted to bring you this
education web seminar presented by
labyrinth lab roots is a leading
scientific social networking website and
producer of educational virtual events
and webinars contributing to the
advancements of science through content
sharing capabilities lab roots as a
powerful advocate and amplifying global
networks and communities we have a few
important announcements before we begin
this webcast is designed to be
interactive and we encourage you to ask
questions during the event you can
submit questions by typing them in the
Q&A box which can be found by clicking
on the green Julian a button at the
lower left of the presentation window
we'll try to answer as many questions as
we can you can enlarge the slide window
by clicking on the screen icon and the
lower right hand corner of the slide
window if you have any technical
problems viewing or hearing this
presentation please click on the support
button at the top right of your
presentation window or submit your
problems through the green Q&A button
lower left I'd like to introduce today's
speaker dr. axel Hansen dr. Hansen
graduated in 1985 and DVM from the Royal
veterinarian agriculture university in
Copenhagen Denmark he was awarded the
degree of Doctor veterinary science
based upon his thesis on the impact of
bacteria and laboratory rats dr. Hansen
is today a professor and laboratory in
animal science and welfare under the
University of Copenhagen she has made
chartered diplomatic and together with
six others founded the European College
of laboratory animal medicine his
research area has primarily been on the
microbiota and an impact on laboratory
models in four slam ettore diseases and
how this works in conjunction with the
diet he has published 158 peer-reviewed
papers and scientific journals and 36
papers and books proceedings or pop
journals I'll now turn it over to dr.
for his presentation Thank You ver thank
you very much but I would like to thank
lab roots and the organizers for
inviting me here today to give a talk
about how to educate and develop a lab
animal vets which is a subject that I
have always liked to to do as pop just
the term by I bet myself I graduated
back in the nineteen eighty-five I've
been working most of my career as a lab
animal read a lab animal science is the
researcher will in lab animal science
and welfare are being employed with a
good a lab animal breeder the facility
in den mud which is today part of the
taconic but also been the lab animal vet
at the University could make in
university hospital for range of
different animal species and today I'm
teaching a veg students house become
future lab animal vets and we are also
having our postgraduate the problem
programs for those who want to continue
their development and this is some of
the things I'm going to talk about today
what are the tasks of the laboratory
animal that we should know something
about the legislation that regulate the
use of the ball so animals we should be
able to communicate this to staff into
the public and societies we should be
aware of ethics animal welfare and thus
we ask we should be familiar with animal
care and management we should be able to
deal with the health issues of the
animals we should know how these animals
are produced by breathing and the
background genetics we should be able to
invest the time so paint treat the
animals of the surgery in them and we
should know how animals are used for
modeling human diseases
and also if you ask the European Union
and if you ask the legislation we should
be familiar with the local environment
that we're working in and why do we need
Wendy postgraduate training lab or
animal medicine in Europe and other
places in the world us and and Asia in
Africa South America and so their best
schools and they graduate that's for
most of these bed schools that seems to
be some sort of curriculum animal
species which are the traditional
peasants force animals and the
production animals also there will be
some in European vet schools and also
some of the us-led schools whether
includes also the lab animals in the
curriculum very much based about whether
they have a large pharmaceutical
industry so also with a veterinary
candidates and Europe all this is
accredited by the european association
for accreditation of veterinary
education however for those vets who
graduate from vet schools were more
traditional curriculum they need to add
on some lab animal medicine chore to
become familiar will love animals and to
be able to work with in this field and
to fulfill the claims for being accepted
as designated vets in the facilities the
need some additional specialist
technology and then leads intractable
training as well the universal and I
would mostly be the vet schools they can
supply some of these knowledge also the
things that has to be added on the top
of the basic veterinary education but
some of it will also have to add on the
job that implies for love the practical
training which is more can
Union to set up in a job situation than
to make more artificially in a school
situation before 2011 we had the old
european union directive which was
actually very weak in the educational
demands for visionary ins it mostly just
told us that they need to be a vet in a
facility we had selasa the european lab
animal sciences creation which has the
category D which was a general category
for experts which was were covered by
the European Union direction was not
solely made up for veterinarians but it
described the education needed to become
a specialist in lab animal science and
then we had the possibility of becoming
a clam diplomat a specialist in lab
animal medicine which was only for vets
the European Union direction those were
the hardcore legal demands but they were
very weak in their wording and the more
specialized recommendation these were
made by nongovernmental organizations
such as fellows and Oakland so they had
no real legal status the philosopher
guidelines for education and specialists
that I just mentioned was a very broad
the group of planes for education of the
specialists but it did not adhere fully
to or only to two veterinarians also
biologists and other was a certain
background would be able to follow
education within this category due to
this broadness did not became the same
success as the other categories of
selasa and why not it attracted
some young deaths who wanted from the
beginning of their career to specialize
in focus on that by animal science but
it also attracted some older more
experienced vet who had been dealing
with other issues during that career but
now wanted to change into becoming lab
animal sciences and it attracted none
that biologists for instance who had a
biological background but wanted to
specialize in lab animal science and the
educational needs for these three groups
that isn't over led very much so that
were it was difficult to set up these
programs and to make them relevant for
these three groups the lab animal let's
have for several decades organized
themselves in the European Society of
laboratory veterinarians s let the S
leva dictates that is to promote and
disseminate expert visionary knowledge
within the scheme of the board's animals
lives they do that through meetings
lectures cetera they advance visionary
and knowledge and skills and subjects
connected with breeding health wealth
and use of laboratory animals and they
collaborate and exchange information
they also encourage their members to
take part in training of other vets and
cover that we have the European college
elbow to animal with medicine let set
standards for postgraduate education in
order to allow that to graduate a
specialist in liberto animal medicine
therefore they establish some
qualification routes which can be the
standard routes or can be some
alternative routes but they should all
be relevant to the assessment of the
candidates qualifications and they
examine that to become specialist
and the other has these continuing
education programs and levels and
medicine eglin has a range of
expectation to the candidates late list
same way as the European Union does that
that animal that should be able to treat
diseases deal with pain and distress
they should train other staff they
should do research support they should
be able to manage animal husbandry
programs understand animal use protocols
overrate facilities control the
environment evil laws and regulations
designed biomedical research contribute
to the humane use of animals contribute
to ethical discussions and help to
promote the wealth and quality at life
of research animals and they're not
alone all over the world you will see
colleges such as a clam what is then the
problem in Europe your of the problem is
there only four eggs and training
programs and when we had this Eliza be
there were only two philosophy programs
and to take part of them you had to be
physically present you had to fly in at
least for a period to stay in hotels and
be away from your ordinary daily job
situation which was not very popular
with the employers who had to do without
their employers for a certain period
every year for them to go somewhere else
to take part in training programs a clam
should be a call of a slab so that of
course would be more as lab members and
some of them would also be eggs and
diplomats
s-lab today consists of some some of
these young veterinarians just in the
beginning of the career and some of the
more experienced missionaries who have
worked in lab animal facilities for many
years when we discussed training the
training needs of these of course
declining village the Youngs they need a
lot of training to be able to develop
the career and lab animal science while
the other ones they had during the job
situation congresses courses etc already
achieved some of these competences which
I needed and they do that have the same
need for systematized the training
programs as a young ones the optimum
situation would be if s labs members was
a young ones who gradually became a clan
to permit so all the older s lab members
they were all a clamp diplomats however
this is not the reality the reality is
that a clamp is to say a very very small
core of a slab it contains very very few
young visionary ins and a lot of the
older more experienced ones some of
those are chartered diplomats such as
myself we actually found it as a good
college and during the first the years
of the college we also allow some
prospective diplomats into to the
college people who already had the
proper qualifications and could help
build up the college after period of two
years the plan was that exams every year
would let in New diplomats among the
younger members of the field however
those are the members still
from the defector diplomats of course
not the child of the village we were
only seven and it's only slowly
progressing to get the young
veterinarians into this college and if
we wait just enough time then of course
all these older a clan members will
leave the College of a more natural
route so to say which will also mean the
death of the college so something has to
be done to allow these young
veterinarians to train and develop the
career in louisville at lovato animal
medicine and to get the combatants as
laboratory animal specialists so reality
also for escalator today is the very
very few of their members they had
eyelids a clamp diplomat stages or the
philoso- ed status doesn't mean that
they're not expert that not just have
been registered as such after 2011 the
European Union change that are rated we
have the new directive on the use of
laboratory animals which was in for from
2000 a surgeon in addition to the
director the European Union has issued a
range of guidance papers how to
understand that are rated probably one
of these is for the education and
training framework within this guidance
paper you can find descriptions of the
different levels of staff which are
going to work will have also animals
this is replacing the older talati
category ABC and be a bit confusing Lee
the European Union is also talking about
function a B and D we will not serve
about today but important thing is that
this guidance paper actual also contains
claims for competences needed by levels
and movies in areas if they're going to
be legally accepted as designated
veterinarians in the laboratory animal
facilities we try to prove this there is
some basic visionary knowledge that
these vision errands need to have the
need to be bet they need to come from
and accept it vet school and should be
able to do the things that that as
opposed to be doing on top of that they
need to add some knowledge within the
water animal science this is not
specific veterinary knowledge this is
actually some of the elements which was
formerly known as philosophy today we'll
see but today is firms function abd in
the European Union guidance paper and
then on travel that they need to add on
some specific convert centers which are
for leather animal dates if they want to
become that animal that it is listed in
the guidance papers what are they be
what should they be able to do and first
when they are proven that they fulfil
these are learning outcomes the European
Union will regard them as fully
competent the ball to animal venerians
the principles knowledge includes
knowledge and national legislation
ethics animal welfare all the basic and
appropriate biology of the species
Animal Care Health and management
regulation of pain suffering distress
humane lizards of killing and some of
the minimally invasive procedures ethics
animal work and the three yards and
something about the silent procedures
some of the things you would also expect
from people holding a license to perform
animal exploitation as i mentioned i
will won't take much into details about
this it is several pages in the guidance
paper that describes and learning
outcomes of this is known as EU
functions AP e but as i mentioned in
addition to that there are specific
veterinary demands in the gardens paper
these are described as the EU modules
for 24 and the EU model 50 for each part
of this there are very detailed learning
outcomes that the vet should be able to
fulfill and that they should prove to
that they are fulfilling and those are
described within the distillation and
visionary communication ethics animal
wealth and the free are animal care and
management the board to animal health
kinetics and breeding and the Stevie
analgesia and surgery animal models of
human diseases introduction to the local
environment that is the logical 50 that
the veterinarian in a certain facility
should be probably introduced to the
local environment in order to be able
also to guide use
ask into this local environment so we go
back to this one we can say that these
EU guidance paper module 24 covers what
needs to be put on top of a basic
visionary education to become a lab for
animal veterinarian this is in my eyes
something which can be probably covered
still by the vegetables but on top of
this also to fulfill the EU guidance
paper you need some current on-the-job
training which needs to be performed on
the job so the learning outcomes actual
only helps you to be able to do you're
on the job practical training so how can
we change the situation in Europe so we
get more laborda animal veterinarians
probably graduated and make them fulfil
this module 24 under the EU guidance
paper i think when i read the guidance
table and philosophy agrees with me and
that is that most of this can actually
be fulfilled by online programs this
will disregard in the future the need
for veterinarians the to travel across
europe to join with a few physically
placed training programs programs which
are placed in system to the region's
compared to where they live or reason i
want to to to work it is actually
possible to do this on a fully online
basis
so it will look at what should be added
to the veterinary education I think it's
the task of the vet schools to supply
the learning outcomes of the module 24
and it's a task of a clamp to supply the
practical on-the-job training to
supervise that and to examine that so
that at the end a young visionary can
graduate as an excellent tickler we have
therefore at our vet school which is a
rather large vet school the only one in
Berlin in Denmark we graduate 8 180
ordinary veterinarians per year but also
as part of the basic visionary education
we actually graduate every year 36 out
of 180 which are already from the basic
education minute specialized in in the
virtual Rhiana milles this is a special
need because in the copenhagen area
there's a huge collection of
pharmaceutical industry which creates
jobs for veterinarians every year so a
lot of the veterinary candidates never
go to visionary practice they go to the
pharmaceutical industry this is not
necessarily situation that is comparable
to a range of other countries where
veterans all of them go to more
traditional a visionary jobs in Denmark
the pharmaceutical industry is the major
path of the national economy and
therefore there is a need for a huge
number lab animal base so we have the
experience also teaching lab animal
science switcher vision errands so we
have developed an online program which
is available for everybody but it wants
to join in
it is organized part by the University
and runs under the quality assurance of
the University it is 30 European credit
transfer programs and it deals with
levels and medicine searches it is
described in the modules of the EU
guidance paper it's only for that
previously we had a theological Rudy
program we have closed down that so we
do not take any other than base for this
program it's one hundred percent online
it's only theory there's some practical
issues you have to do at home but what
you get from us is the theory it's full
adherent to the new consensus paper and
we have achieved philosophy keishon
according to this you guidance paper and
compared to our old mauser program it's
much much cheaper because it's fully
online and on the trouble that you don't
have to travel so in that way it's also
achiever it can be found by entering a
home page which will guide you into to
the program of course there are some pre
demands to enter the program you will
have to be a bit you will need to have
two years working experience before you
you join so you cannot just click on the
internet and get into the program there
are some admissions criteria which we
have agreed will salasa about that we
have to check before you let you in but
you can of course start visiting this
with the home page if you just want to
see what is about and everybody can do
that we have a basic version which is
online so by paying will your credit
card a license fee of 250 yours you can
actually get into the system and you can
see most of the latest and you would do
a range of the tests that we do with the
participant but we won't be there to t
two and we're going to be there to
discuss and I answer your questions but
you can see what what is this but to be
certified from this to the program you
need to enter the full program with your
30 ECT is in that that would be some
online teaching it is mainly the same
material as we have on the basic version
there will be teacher and student
interaction over the Internet is there
would be some reports that you need to
write and there be a local coordinator
in your region that you can access to
discuss some practical matters and just
as its participation in the program will
be evaluated afterwards and you will get
F Eliza accredited certificate at the
end to help people into the program we
have arranged with some co lasers
different places in the world so that
people can talk talk to them and they
can help these people get in into the
program and they can help them along the
way if they have practical matters they
want to discuss you were also during the
program need to find a local supervisor
to help you write reports on the local
legislation that can be the coordinator
but it could also be some other
qualified person also if you want to
talk to us and ask questions out loud
the program just want to hear about it
that without actually i'm joined the
program we have a Facebook page that you
can can enter and the Hindus and the
three different elements of the program
what we offer in this lab that your
program that is performance of these
specific visionary learning outcomes but
is of course also possible to do the
other part of the EU guidance paper so
you
reason if you just have a basic
veterinary education and you do not
fulfill the other demands of the
European Union then we also have a
possibility of taking most of this
online also in the philosopher edited
version this of course implies that
there are some practical sessions that
you have to join she will have to spend
some time in Copenhagen to to do the
tray tables but I think this is a way
that many more courses cook the oven
worldwide let participants only spent a
short time physically present at the
course organizer to do practicals while
remaining part of the course the
teaching of the theory can easily be
done online so we demand if you want to
join the ABD part of the course that you
come for two days to curb megan and then
you can go back home again and do the
remaining part of the course through the
internet when you enter for instance the
letter program you'll start by just
getting a list of the difference of the
different modules and I'm not going to
dig into those I showed you they've
those from these you guidance paper this
before but if you click on one of the
modules will get into page will sign the
different materials we always start with
a welcome video so within each module
there will be a video instructing you
what to do if you want to beach fault
within this module there will also be
something you have to read yourself
they'll be a reading list of something
you simply have to get get books papers
or so and read and study yourself
they'll be some some videos which have
been produced by the University of
Copenhagen video department which in a
more what you can say Discovery Channel
away shows the issues that you're going
to learn but there will also be some
more traditional pictures and we have
some e tivities some quizzes some
reports something that you had to do and
we'll get a feedback on some of this is
mandatory and some is more voluntary we
use these two boots as the curriculum
that you need to read and those are
quite comprehensive oops but you should
also be aware that further European
credit transfer points that is actually
have a year full time work also a
possibility that we use and that others
can use as well as they want to set up
similar programs is that there's
actually a conversion system available
where they sell access to internet
lectures and there's and lab animal
science section within these Andrew
Stuart talks so we use some of these in
your Stewart jokes to have other experts
than ourselves to give input to things
such as sa anesthesia animal modeling
reading of animals and so and it's
actually
from discover the truth by a single
latest so so if you're part of our
program you can actually also here on
the other lectures if you want to and
find interesting in that we arrange all
our exams in an online version to be
able to exam people online apart from
one claim that is examination of
practical capabilities of course we need
to assure is there is a practical
element as there is in our abd part of
the educational program then we need to
assess on site that people are
performing probably so while being with
us in Copenhagen there are some certain
skills that an instructor will have to
check with you that you are capable of
doing after having taken part in the
practicals and there we are quite
old-fashioned we have a MTG card that
the participant will train and bring a
print and bring with them and will be
signed by the instructor if the skill is
performed excessively another challenge
that is this geographical dispersion
people cannot fly into to to to have
exams which are in the show time so we
need to be able to do this this in the
online wave but it can actually be done
we have two exams on the left their
program for instance the written exam
and lesson oral exam some part of the
curriculum is covered by the written
exam and some parts of the curriculum is
covered by the oral exam the written
exam is for hours and is
fully online and the examine can be
placed wherever he or she preferred to
be they just need the computer they can
use all the help in tools they want to
also if they want to do live and
electronic communications along the road
while doing the exams then they can do
that they just have to hand in the reply
within four hours but we had secured
that we can still examine them although
the actual have access to also
discussing the issues with other experts
in the fields the most honest statement
that the person of right all replies and
the computers so of course if they have
somebody not being yourself to write the
replies this is a criminal act and as we
get all the answers online then we check
automatically for player reason and that
will of course lead to failure but also
we can also be used as a rejection from
the program if the violation is severe
we also have the oil exam at the oral
exam be 48 hours before the exam starts
we keep the examine and eight different
the subjects from the curriculum they
have to prepare a 20-minute presentation
including electronic slices at least
ones i'm using now on each of these
subjects and at the end of the period
we'll make ourselves online with the
students and they will grow one of these
presentations and they will present it
at both the ribbon and the old examiner
there will be one of the teachers and
they'll be an external examiner for
instance and XM diplomat we have a card
from the industry or whoever it could be
especially there has to be recognized by
the university as
a centers for this this type of exam and
then of course we need to secure when
you plan the exam that exam actually
secure that the students fulfill the
learning outcomes I previously together
with gold apart Wisconsin who is one of
the other teachers and this is a program
written this paper in the lab animal
journal where you can read more about
the strategies for assessment of
competence on these levels of animal
science courses and our experience for
instance by doing online exams surely I
can say we'll have good experiences we
have also examined a number of students
online on the old master programs we
have also rejected some of them do two
attempts to play your reason so at the
f'ing course while while stealing things
from the internet and using replies not
minute but it shows that the system
works for those participate in our let
that program we also offer them to join
the acre and XM training program the let
that your program will then be the
didactic apart and as part of the a
client claims they need to do two
projects at home that they can publish
and they can get supervision for that
and the needs to be a practical past
they will do that in their own
facilities but if they're in facilities
do not have all the species which are
claimed by Eggland's they need to go
somewhere else for periods there will be
a personal education plan for them they
can get they must get supervision by an
acclaimed diplomat that we will arrange
for
some of the supervision will be long
distance but they're also need to meet
with the excellent diplomat skype or
physically they will have a visit and
side from the supervisor and we offered
to make some waving us for those who are
part of this program and we'll make some
tests exams for them the disadvantage if
there's any part by this is that I have
to join this training as quickly as
possible because the need to be in rows
in this alternate training for a minimum
of three years and it only counts from
the day they actually drove into the
program and they should allow them to
enter the final exam exam and hopefully
it should also allow them to pass so by
this we hope we can add to having more
Oakland diplomats in Europe and make it
a claim as successful as the American
College Eklund has been for four decades
that was my joke I thank you very much
for listening
we
very much for that informative
presentation before we get to the
question the answer section I would like
to remind our audience how to submit
questions you can submit questions by
typing them in the Q&A box which can be
found by clicking on the green Q&A
button at the lower left of the
presentation window we're going to try
to answer as many questions as we
possibly can all questions that we're
not able to get to will be answered
offline our first question for you dr.
is do you think that were being mean to
train certain number of non
veterinarians in the future as it is
done in the old European category D yes
that that's of course a good question I
think that will I don't think it will be
huge but if we look around and the
facilities the veterinarians they do not
have all the positions and you can say
some of the other basic education so
that the universe's offer of us could
actually also be more relevant for some
of the other positions many of the
managers they have a basic education
rather within the animal science then
and for instance also more basic biology
then then they're not all of it in
errands so they would be need also to
train them and actually also the
European Union gardens papers they have
a module which is which describes the
learning outcomes for managers so I
think in the future we will also see
online programs between the managers and
those that can be a variety of other
basic education which would enter search
it such that programs I don't think the
majority of those who will train train
as a specialist they will be
veterinarians but i'm quite confident
that we
the other programs as well
thank you in our next question is how do
you assure that the examiners are not
just spending their time on calling
friends to help them when they do the
written online exams your cookie cook
fear when you have these examiners see
that they have access to to the entire
world it could be like it's a no these
these the quiz programmes that you
couldn't ask the audience you can call
it a friend and and and so and actually
they they they can can do that but but
it's this very intimate forum I can say
that there are some tricks that you can
can use to prevent them from from
spending all the time to doing that and
enter one of the most important fix that
is to overwhelm them with the presence
of what what we do is that that we we
calculate how long time will it take you
to reply to this equation if you know
the answer so and then you will add it
all up and then you make sure that
there's very little time to to actually
do anything else and then typing it on
the computer so securing for instance
for our exam you would allow them 10 12
15 minutes or so to live into to do so
to do other things but if they sit
reading in the books all the time if
they they color friends so they re watch
the videos of what whatever and it means
that going to spend all that the time
time doing that and they won't be able
to reply to a sufficient amount of the
questions to the tube able to pass the
exam so I think that works quite well
and I don't think actually reached a
verdict sense these are very much from
from the way minerals other ways we
extend
the students the students they also hint
handing be ports and so there's a right
of him and of course they can get all
possible help and McMinn of the young
student sections do you to get that from
from the parents and so so so life is
not overly said fair so so to to to say
so also from any other thing to do you
cannot really control how much help that
they get so in this way a very short
time online exam is actually a much more
strict because there are capable of
doing much much else when actually
replying to questions we give them and
if they they cover from the internet or
books or whatever they do the player is
in systems that will catch it
immediately and they will fail the exam
well that is a very thorough and
comprehensive system very glad that that
is in place so we look like we have time
for one last question here then again i
want to remind our audience and all the
additional questions will be answered
via email how long are how much time
what does it take to pastor your entire
exam through the animal vet program
yes in principle as in the European
credit transfer system one year of
studies that 60 pts appoints an hour our
program is 30 it is program should you
should be able to do it half half a year
but but I mean as all these trainees
right there having jobs full-time jobs
about while doing this it's obvious that
nobody will be able to to do that so and
so far the program has shown you so we
haven't graduated any get that I can see
from the progress that that they make
that the fastest one they are probably
able to do it in a year or a year and a
half or so so the first one which
entered the program when we started a
year ago they would probably be examined
in summertime but I think many of them
will spend to spend more more time and
some of them might even spend three or
four years before we see them at the
exam but I think that's one of the
wonderful things with having these
online assistance that if you avoid
having too many real-time events and so
then they can actually work with with a
huge flexibility some can do that at a
very rapid speed and some can take more
time time to subdue it so so even though
sometimes when I sit with the program i
get a bit annoyed that sort of thing the
students are too slow in that their
progression I think it's a big advantage
that they actually could do it at the
room that speed
well thank you dr. Hansen for your time
today and for your presentation before
we let you go do you have any final
comments I hope that I have given you a
short introduction to how these things
can be be organized and my hope is that
we in the future can have much more
training of lab animal deaths then then
we have had until the date of course
doing things online you will miss the
physical contact with the the
participants but i think the huge
advantage fully counteracted and that is
that you're able of training far more
far more people worldwide also in areas
where veterinary training has previously
not been available tools they can join
these programs so thing will also
hopefully see specialists also in more
distant regions outside of europe
outside the US sensor so that is my eyes
open i hope i have added a bit to this
and i have been very happy to to to join
this lab roots conference thank you very
much for inviting me
well doctors are privileged and honored
to have you today I'd also like to thank
our sponsor lavage for making today's
educational webcast possible today's
webcast will be available for on-demand
viewing through May 2017 you'll receive
an email from lab roots alerting you
when this webcast will be available for
replay we invite you to for that
announcement to your colleagues who have
made missed today's live event and until
next time goodbye